all right so I guess David Ayer was like
you know that Joker reveal really worked
out everyone loved that so let's show
more it's probably the exact opposite at
that point is we have a picture of
everyone in the Suicide Squad in costume
there for us and on Twitter people
wanted to hear my opinion so here's my
opinion but looks really cool I like
lining them up and seeing everywhere
like oh my god that's the crew that's
the squad some are more impressive than
others but I'll know you're looking at
it and it does look and feel like hey
that's the Suicide Squad Captain
Boomerang is rocking the duct-tape leg
holster drops to that man you rock that
[ __ ] like a champ getting right into it
the two that looked the most impressive
are the two I thought would look the
most impressive I don't know why maybes
because I know most about them but
Margot Robbie is Harley Quinn and Will
Smith as Deadshot both look awesome
I mean look at Harley Quinn you're like
that is absolutely Harley Quinn Deadshot
same thing he doesn't have the eye peas
because some people like lawyers have
the eye peas but I was thinking we'll
probably show how he gets the eyepiece
thing but then another picture was
tweeted was like a hey here's Will Smith
in full costume with the mask and the IP
I only it's not even a gripe it's just
kind of a detail he's holding the gun
like he's right-handed but the eyepiece
is on the left so it's like he's gonna
hold the gun to his right eye and the
eyepiece isn't going to be looking
through the scope and I was really
thinking about that I was looking up
other pictures of Deadshot and generally
speaking the eyepiece is on the right
eye I don't know that it really matters
that you feel like it's gonna be one of
those things when the Wii Zelda had link
hold the sword with his right hand and
some fans were like duh sacrilege is
supposed to be the left hand brace
yourself David Ayer the keyboard
Crusaders I'm not gonna lie I don't know
everyone in this era like the dude on
the right I had to look it up I believe
I was supposed to be a guy named El
Diablo I know nothing about it I'm just
gonna call him zombie peaked in high
school Rob looks he still has
Letterman's jacket on so that's who he
is to me zombie peaked in high school
Rob Lowe the lady in the front named
katana I know that because I have her
hero clique it's really most of what I
know about her her costumes kind of
funny I don't know if it's so accurate
it's right on the nose am i good job or
it looks like cosplaying cuz it looks
like a costume which is why pictures are
worth a thousand words but videos worth
a thousand pictures I guess I need to
see this stuff in action or to be like
oh hey yeah good job not pictured here
is Jared Leto as the Joker cuz we
already got a picture of him which a lot
of people had a lot to say about the
tattoos but I don't think he's pictured
here because I don't I never thought he
was gonna be part of the Suicide Squad
like the Joker is gonna be the one
they're hunting or the bad guy in the
Suicide Squad if he's gonna be like in a
Cell being all like ah the beans in a
nice candy I don't think he's gonna be
working with the squad I feel like if
he's going to work with the squad he's
working with the squad simply for his
own ends so we can escape or you know
raise the city to the ground or some
[ __ ] and Viola Davis is Amanda Waller is
not here which I don't think you need a
real reveal for Amanda Waller I don't
feel like you do maybe you do I feel
like unofficially she's just gonna look
like this
unofficial Amanda Waller pick Viola
Davis as Amanda Waller that's a really
good choice though Killer Croc is
straight-up legit Killer Croc he does
have the thing going on where it's like
a lot of makeup on his head and it kind
of looks like Michael Jai White and
spine there's like so much makeup the
head and shoulders look so much bigger
than the rest of the body
in the end guys we got a pic of the
Suicide Squad in costume all lined up
together and I thought it was pretty
cool
we're talking about Ultron all the time
there's other [ __ ] in the world but I
really want to know what you guys think
about it so the Suicide Squad pic
tweeted by David Ayer have you seen it a
guy stop saying that what I'm talking
about picture reveals when I show the
picture into my fit he oh now that
you've seen it what do you think about
it whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you